[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola soy ver su franco su franquista soy
director soy músico y
quiero hablarles de varias experiencias
que he tenido en la vida sobre todo en
cuanto a a encontrarme a mí mismo en
cuanto a mi orientación vocacional que
fue desde niño desde los 11 años que
descubrí esta flauta que fue la flauta
dulce la flauta de pico que quicler
instituye en las escuelas secundarias
desde los años 30
que finalmente fue el último lo más bien
el único instrumento en el que tuve yo
contacto al que tuve yo el único que
puede tocar para ser pianista a raíz de
una chica claudia aguirre que tocaba el
piano en un salón de la escuela la
secundaria 35 en la ciudad de méxico y
que desde que oí mozart una sonata de
mozart ese está adentro
[Música]
etcétera etcétera
el día que hoy esa obra tocada por ella
me facto m me dio total y absolutamente
pues una
[Música]
yo lo podría llamar una epifanía una
epifanía de
de esa maravillosa música que es me
reveló al cerebro y yo no quise hacer
otra cosa más que eso eso me trajo con
consecuencias pues muchísimos problemas
en mi casa porque ellos mis padres que
mis padres eran gente muy muy muy buena
como padres y quieren lo mejor para sus
hijos pero no sabían que querían para
sus hijos más bien querían que sus hijos
fueran médicos abogados ingenieros o
alguna carrera que ellos no pudieran
tener y en ese momento que yo les digo
yo quiero ser músico pues obviamente se
me m
sin
se viene el mundo encima porque para
ellos eso no era una carrera para ella
me dijo esto no es una carrera primero
tienes que estudiar una carrera que te
dé dinero que te dé status etcétera
etcétera y seguí mi ser en camino seguir
mi camino buscando mis medios quería ser
pianista por el ejemplo de esta chica no
pude nunca porque mi casa no me iban a
comprar un piano verdad y tampoco dinero
para eso era la gente mis padres a la
gente que vivíamos al día realmente y
pues tuve que conformarnos con la flauta
y bueno fue el sueño que hasta la fecha
tocó como profesión principal porque
también dirijo pero la intuición y soy
maestro del conservatorio también entré
hace muchos años el hecho es que siempre
hice lo que quise realmente me sentía yo
como la locomotora de ello tenía una
estamina de hacer lo que tenía que hacer
que era estudiar música y pues entre el
conservatorio escondidas de mis papás
después a los 17 en el estudio era
holanda había yo he hecho planes de
estudio de una carrera prototipo de
flauta dulce que estuve dando clases ahí
y en la superior de música
cuando regrese de estudiar de holanda
habían perdido los planes de estudio y
pues nunca los volviese al hasta hace
poco no pero bueno ya habían clases de
flauta dulce y de fraude ético
profesionales en otras escuelas entonces
me dediqué a darles metodologías de
estudio música de cámara interpretación
de la música perú bizcocho vocal después
de que a grecia de manera o en holanda
muy fieros 17 años sin becas y sin nada
más fue porque habían ganado un año de
dar clases en el conservatorio y en la
superior de música y me dan un premio en
sí propia de británica gracias a eso me
pude ir a un lado pero bueno regresando
hablando pues tuve que hacer una carrera
misma que ha durado ya pues más de 35
unos 35 años ya en mayo cumplió 35 años
que llegué de estudiar y de holanda muy
joven a los 21 años recién regresé a
méxico no puede dar clases de flauta
dulce también en la nacional de música
que hoy su facultad de música etcétera
etcétera bueno
después de eso vinieron las giras
vinieron obviamente ya los conciertos de
las giras
forman grupos de música barroca con
gente muy importante en méxico como
organizador bombo lleno suaviza de josé
suárez estuve tocando mucho con
orquestas como solista de orquestas
empecé una carrera de dirección y
finalmente no me arrepiento de nada de
que haya hecho yo porque
lo que quisiera decirles es que de todo
lo que he logrado que no son muchos
bienes materiales pero finalmente una
carrera que me importa mucho más que
cualquier bien material es precisamente
con trabajo con esfuerzo y con una
disciplina la cual finalmente es una una
de las armas principales que tenemos los
seres humanos para poder lograr lo que
queremos lograr en la vida en méxico
vivimos en una sociedad siempre lo he
dicho es como la sociedad hindú la
sociedad de castas pero estamos en el
closet ya no tanto ya hay mucho más
apertura ya enviar a la gente que es
hija de nadie puede llegar a lograr
cosas importantes no puede llegar a
tener un patrimonio pero le cuesta mucho
trabajo así como me costó a mí
a la gente muy pobre le cuesta muchísimo
trabajo llegar a ser alguien
todos somos alguien pero finalmente la
repartición de la riqueza en nuestro
país ha sido tan deplorable y tan mal
administrada no en sexenio sino en
siglos desde que llegaron los españoles
a méxico desde que todo lo polarizar
only y pues sometieron a los indígenas
etcétera etcétera pues ya conocemos la
historia no necesito repetirla tenemos
además una independencia muy muy
cuestionable también una evolución muy
cuestionable y todo el poder en icod es
y seguirá siendo muy cuestionable
esperemos que este sexenio salga mejor
ojalá porque así lo deseamos todos pero
la cuestión aquí es que a mí me gustó
mucho trabajo y ese trabajo me ha sabido
siempre muy bien me ha sabido pues en
realidad
no es que me haya costado poco es que lo
hice y lo hice porque lo tenía que hacer
si quieres algo que en esta vida te
te llene de felicidad que es lo que
buscamos o lo que deberíamos buscar en
la vida no el dinero no el bienestar
económico no la forma tampoco sino la
felicidad que es lo que a mí me da
felicidad pues hacer música dirigir
música estar en contacto con músicos y
estar en contacto con el público también
y dar lo mejor de mí para el público
entonces en ese sentido la felicidad
para mí es esa soy un hombre realmente
plenamente feliz vivo de lo que hago y
no necesito realmente grandes fortunas
ni tampoco fama como para seguir siendo
muy felices solo que eso no importa una
de las cosas también que aprendí a hacer
y que bueno también quería yo más o
menos concluir esta charla con con esto
con el tema de la de más actualidad del
coi 19 de la cual pues fui víctima no me
contagié en una gira que tuve en marzo
pero en marzo en nueva york pues regresé
con un souvenir de nueva york que fue
precisamente pues que me atacó este
nuevo que a todos nos trae de cabeza
aunque va a cambiar mucho las dinámicas
sociales del mundo que va a traer como
consecuencia un desmoronamiento también
de las economías y tal vez un cambio en
las formas de gobernar yo en cambio las
formas de de repartir la riqueza no esto
se viene se viene muy interesante creo
que en ese sentido bueno
el día que me entero obviamente que soy
positivo de kobe 19 no es que me haya
dado el gran pánico pero todo esto tiene
antecedentes en a lo que les voy a decir
y que es muy importante muy muy
importante para todos yo soy una persona
que teniendo los antecedentes genéticos
que tengo de padres hermanos
y buenos padres y hermanos de ambos que
hay diabetes
murieron mi papá era diabético mis tíos
también todos vestidos o muchos de mis
tíos
por parte de mi mamá más hipertensos
artríticas a mi madre también y bueno
hay demencia también en hermanos hay una
enfermedad hereditaria del corazón en la
hermana que murió de cáncer en tres de
mis hermanos
entonces yo desde hace mucho me compré
un seguro de vida un seguro de vida qué
significa estar sana estar sano y estar
en verdad al tiro como decimos aquí en
méxico estará el tiro con la salud con
la alimentación con el ejercicio soy una
persona que ha hecho haber sido los
últimos 30 años de mi vida que me he
nutrido bien y comido muy bien los
últimos 20 también y yo creo que he
aprendido a comer muy bien orgánico y
mont son muy meticulosos filmus
quisquilloso y quiero en nueva york más
cuando esta mayoría de febrero y en
marzo principios de marzo pues a mí no
pasar nada a mí nunca va a pasar nada
como pasará algo a mí si sois anglo no
si estoy
si hago ejercicio diario uno de gira voy
al gimnasio no me dejo de alimentar bien
esté donde esté
y no sé qué es muy chistoso pero también
hay otra cosa muy importante en
noviembre en otra gira la nueva york
medio como un cierto tipo de
enfriamiento a partir de una gala en la
que toque y que estoy hablando después
había una fiesta y con una banda de jazz
muy buena pero estuve hablando muy muy
alto habla hable hable grité mucho
porque no había otra manera de
comunicarse con con los interlocutores y
me dio una ronquera es alucinante que
después se me me volvió una tos que no
se me quitó hasta diciembre no y yo
estaba decepcionada una norme pasa nada
'estos nada más no pues no no no yo creo
que esa tos que después regresó con
varios aires acondicionados a los que me
vi expuestos por por ir a tocar a
mazatlán ya cancún dos conciertos los
aires acondicionados de los aviones son
terribles son son de los aviones y de
los de los aeropuertos
entonces me volvió un poco es a todos ya
me fui en nueva york que en febrero
sin las dos pero toda mi gente nunca
nunca se me quitó tan bien como yo
hubiera querido ya y no ver no tenían a
de todos
y lo que les puedo decir de esto es que
yo no había escuchado a mi cuerpo uno
tiene que escuchar a su cuerpo no tiene
que estar consciente de cómo escuchar y
claro ya salí avante del cob y ya salí
finalmente pues todavía no anticuada
coordinada porque eso va a tardar mucho
tiempo pero me estoy recuperando casi
del 100% pero lo más importante de esto
es que no te confíes aunque tengas muy
buena salud aunque seas muy joven aunque
seas total y absolutamente un deportista
como lo soy yo en realidad no te confíes
porque nadie tiene garantizado que no te
vas a enfermar de algo oye tu cuerpo mi
última reflexión aquí escucha tu cuerpo
y siente lógico 200 de algo
inmediatamente reacciona y siempre
comparte ese seguro de vida que es la
alimentación correcta la alimentación
justa y buena la cosa orgánica las
cuestiones naturales no y sobre todo
hace ejercicio y cultiva tu mente con
algo que además si te gusta muchas
gracias
[Música]